This episode of DNews is proudly brought to
you by Subaru.
BY TESLA WE'VE GOT IT!
Wireless electricity might be coming to a
home near you...
y'know.
Someday.
Greetings programs, Trace here for DNews.
In 1897, Nikola Tesla — asexual genius and
inventor extraordinaire — wanted to QUOTE
"turn the whole world into a giant wireless
dynamo."
He was awarded a patent in 1907 for wireless
electricity but then the Great War began and
the whole thing was lost to history.
Now, over a century later, researchers at
MIT created wireless power transmission which
could realize his dream!
Sort of.
While Tesla was trying to power cities, this
transmits wireless power around your house!
Your phone, car, television, laptop, game
console, controllers, remotes, toaster and
every lightbulb in every frickin' lamp could
all be powered by magnetic resonators.
The Faraday Law of Induction describes how
an electromagnet creates a magnetic field.
When an electrified coil of wire is wrapped
around a metal rod, the metal magnetizes.
Similarly, when you pass a magnet THROUGH
an unpowered coil of wire, the magnet creates
electricity.
Physics is awesome.
Researchers at MIT found a way to turn simple
physics into a wireless way to transmit electricity
using a similar technology to WiFi.
By plugging in a resonator to the alternating
current outlet in your wall, the device creates
a magnetic oscillation.
The magnetic field of the resonator is large
enough to mingle with nearby coils installed
in the walls and floors of your house — and
ultimately into every device and BOOM wireless
power.
One magnetic coil influences another and another
all over the house.
It's like the barking chain in 101 Dalmatians!
MIT spun off the technology into a funny named
company called WiTricity.
The system can already power televisions,
cell phones and keep their special AA batteries
fully charged all at the same time!
To be honest, induction charging has been
around for a while, as has wireless power
transmission.
Radio waves are wireless power, the pads you
can buy to charge your cell phone, mouse or
game controllers use wireless power, but this
is a bit different.
The ones we have now use near-field induction
and this blows it into a whole new proportion.
The problem with any of these systems, is
the efficiency.
Magnetic fields have to be relatively close-by
to pick up other magnetic fields.
The MIT researchers were able to power one
60 watt light bulb from 2 meters away — but
it was only 45% efficient.
So they put in 133 watts to power a 60 watt
bulb.
Not awesome; though according to the researchers,
this system is 1 million times more efficient
than the ones already on the market... and
the CEO of WiTricity says it's 1,000 times
more efficient than a battery!
This works with both OLD and NEW technology.
Just because it's old doesn't mean it's not
awesome.
Just ask Tekzilla's Patrick Norton - Pat customized
3 high-mileage Subaru cars for 3 charity-minded
owners, so they can keep doin' their thing
& helping the world.
Check out Pat's handy work on the Second Chance
Subaru series at revision3.com/subaru.
If you want wireless power in YOUR house,
click Like and tell us what you'd use it for
down below!
See you next time on DNews.